his réunion 2014 une green mercredi
avait raconté l'agression dont elle
avait été victime au salon de l'auto à
paris après avoir mis en cause le comité
miss réunion qui avait selon elle ne
l'avait qu'ils ne l'avaient pas soutenu
dans cette épreuve elle avait été
suspendue et était entré en conflit
ouvert avec le comité à propos de son
contrat de travail dans un jour avec ce
soir elle témoigne sur ce rêve qui pour
elle a viré au cauchemar jean marc
collienne et daniel fontaine l'ont
rencontré nous avons rendez vous ce
matin avec ingrid mercredi l'ancienne
miss réunion rapide dans cette résidence
des hauts de saint-denis à nous attend
après avoir perdu son titre de miss
réunion in great mercredi est partie
vivre deux ans à nice elle est de retour
depuis quelques mois
bien décidée après on aura passé à autre
chose a bougé moi on s'est débrouillé
les médias pourquoi souvenir d'eux
miss réunion ici non on va dire que j'ai
tourné la page
donc on retrouve vraiment que du positif
que du mois d'août et du présent sur
tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec ingrid nour visionnant les images
de la finale miss réunion 2014 miss
réunion 2014 et qui était si bas les
mains qui tremblent les yeux qui qui
plus est la miss réunion 2014 et la
candidate numéro 3 il gribouille
[Applaudissements]
qui tombe dans les pommes en a perdu
manar et la tan mascara qui coûta la
couronne qui tiennent pas ta langue
youku a les pieds qui font mal mais
hélas quand tu as été élu tu te dis ça
va être que du bonheur on nous avait dit
que voilà ça va être compliqué on est
quand même 12 et une fois que vous serez
une princesse en fait donc là pour moi
là à ce moment là j'étais d'une
princesse a signé sa commande pour être
bien de vanille mais très vite ingrid
déchantent
trois mois plus tard elle participe au
salon de l'auto à paris le mondial de
l'automobile c'est le moment où ça
bascule pour toi c'est un déclic je
pense tu as eu vraiment l'impression de
vivre une agression sexuelle
ah mais oui clairement je parti aux
toilettes
donc j'étais accompagné et
à ce moment là l'autre personne va dans
les toilettes et je l'attend dehors et
il ya quelqu'un qui arrive mais qu'ils
m'attrapent les fesses carrément qu'une
les agripper pas juste une main comme ça
mais il me les a grip
il me tire vers l'arrière du cou jeu
j'ai un peu lâché victoire parce que
j'avais des talons et au moment où je me
retourne et où je crie ils courent donc
l'autre personne je l'appelle je
l'appelle elle vient dit qu'est ce qui
se passe je lui explique
il fait à bombannes toute façon il était
reparti pas grave
à ce moment là
je m'attendais à un peu plus de
d'accompagnement de recherche de et
confirme donc on compatit second tour
parce qu'au final je me sentais
clairement comme la mascotte du salon
pour le coup j'ai l'impression que vous
n'avez pas pris au sérieux ce qui était
arrivé clairement mais c'était aussi
comme si ce n'était pas bien grave a
clairement oui oui oui mais ce qui m'a
sidéré le plus c'est que en voyant donc
en dénonçant tout ça j'ai eu des
articles qui sont qui ont paru sur sur
internet par exemple et des filles ou
des femmes qui commentent en disant mais
ce juste une main aux fesses je veux
dire non mais on est où là
jeudi 12hoo on a le droit de me poser
enfin me toucher les fesses déjà et vous
êtes des femmes un peu de dignité
j'ai envie de dire c'est pas quelque
chose qui qui doit passer inaperçu des
souvenirs que fait remonter aujourd'hui
la farewell stein
mais on a l'impression qu'ici à la
réunion à part toi personne ne sait
vraiment exprimer pourtant tu as
l'impression que forcément ça existe ici
aussi
oui oui ça c'est sûr c'est existee siens
et surtout surtout l'eau vive à notre
nouvelle miss réunion 2014
est-ce que tu as l'impression que le
monde dennis est également touchée et
que tu n'es pas un cas unique
bien sûr j'en suis même persuadé pour
avoir parlé à plusieurs miss ou dauphine
ou et j'en suis sûr après l'agression au
salon de l'auto ingrid se sent de plus
en plus mal le rôle de miss lui pèse
elle n'a pas envie de toujours se faire
belle pour sortir alors elle reste
terrée chez elle jusqu'à tomber en
dépression
on est parti voir un psy et à partir de
là c'est lui qui est un mot qui a vu
qu'en fait je enfin qu en fait j'étais
dans une prison dorée que j'avais pas le
droit de faire signer finissent à nice a
ni d'aller manger un pain bouchon 139,1
pierre et il me disait est ce que c'est
ce que est ce que tu es heureuse et à
cette question je crois que j'ai dû
prendre trois jours et y répondre parce
que j'avais pas envie de dire non parce
que j'étais mise et en même temps j'ai
envie de dire oui parce que ben ça me
semblait pas et que j'avais pas un
moment
aujourd'hui ingrid est revenu à ses
premières amours car avant d'être miss
elle était sportive elle a été
championne de la réunion de bmx
elle a participé aux championnats du
monde est aujourd'hui à nouveau elle
s'entraîne dur
passée la bonne seconde
après avoir perdu son titre de miss
réunion
l'ancienne championne de bmx s'est lancé
dans le krav maga ce sport de combat
pratiqué par les soldats israéliens
elle a même participé au championnat de
france et aujourd'hui elle se lance dans
le crosstour
e
non mon rêve a toujours été le même si
juste miss réunion ne faisait pas
forcément partie mon rêve principal mais
on va dire que ça fait quand même du
bien de sortir un peu des dés
habitudes et puis ça m'a fait une
nouvelle expérience non toute façon mon
rêve va continuer c'est le sport le
sport le sport réussir dans la vie
voilà on en rit se sent aussi un lac
gelé
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui ingrid a totalement
changé de look fini le look miss réunion
aujourd'hui c'est ingrid motards de
robes plus de hauts talons ingrid porte
aujourd'hui basket et blouson
[Musique]
cet après midi c'est avec sa maman
qu'elle part se balader cette maman qui
l'avait poussé à se présenter à miss
région et qui le regrette amèrement
aujourd'hui ce qui se passait après vous
en reparler souvent d'entre vous un des
fois mais c'est rare parce que c'est
quand même une prendre une grande
blessure parce que ça fait mal
surtout en tant que maman pourquoi parce
que ce qu'on a fait à ma fille
je n'accepte pas
n'accepte pas c'est trop dur
j'ai vécu cette aventure à faux avec m
et franchement ça m'a fait pour être
très très mal
clermont j'aurais pu remonter le temps
je l'aurais jamais fait s'y ajoute une
petite fille sera pas de se présenter à
miss réunion
ce sera pas un conseil par contre il
assisterait beaucoup si jamais elle veut
faire comme ça non on
je serai
jusque là je serai je serait pire qu'un
dragon là ce sera ma fille ce sera pas
moi donc je sais où je mets les pieds
maintenant on ne m'y reprendra pas oui
la moto alors du craag
[Musique]